france télécom ouvre de nouvelles
fréquences pour le radio téléphone pour
l'instant c'est plutôt l'embouteillage
et les demandes sont de plus en plus
nombreuse l'administration vient
d'ailleurs de lancer un nouveau plan
d'investissement et développement un
secteur où les choses vont beaucoup
bouger dans les prochaines années a
remporté à jean jacques peyraud henri
adam shine pouvoir téléphoner de sa
voiture ou sur sa moto est encore en
france un luxe et un privilège un luxe à
cause du prix à payer 15 à 20 mille
francs pour l'achat de l'appareil et 300
francs mensuels en moyenne pour
l'abonnement un privilège aussi puisque
les deux réseaux actuels un public un
privé desservent 270 abonnés environ
mais seront bientôt saturer la bande de
fréquences utilisées pour les
radiocommunications dans tous les pays
du monde en france particulièrement est
essentiellement utilisé par les forces
armées cela dit france télécom donc la
paire international négocié actuellement
avec les forces armées et et cela passe
très bien
la pénurie des téléphones mobiles va
trouver d'autres solutions dans les
années qui viennent
la première est un nouveau réseau gsm
réseaux numériques et européens
la deuxième solution elle tient dans ma
poche et elle s'appelle ou untel
pourrait l'utiliser et la fin à 91 à
strasbourg 92 à paris et en suisse dans
tous les sites urbains
cette antenne vous met en relation avec
une borne
il y en aura plusieurs centaines
dispersés dans la ville et grâce à cela
vous pourrez vous appeler un
correspondant n'importe où dans le monde
nous parlait en revanche lui ne pourra
pas vous appeler ce système coûtera
énormément moins cher que les systèmes
actuels et il faudrait marquer la
démocratisation des téléphones mobiles
restera le phénomène des années 90